way back in the summer of last year mark
german gave us a bombshell leak claiming
that apple is working on a redesign of
the ipad pro with a glass back for the
2022 release
yes i said glass back just like we've
had for years with the iphone and if
you're wondering why in the world apple
would do this well it's because apple
apparently wants to enable wireless
charging on the back of the ipad pro
which might sound a bit ridiculous but
the plan is actually genius first of all
mark says it'll support both wireless
charging and reverse wireless charging
kind of like what we currently have with
apple's mac safe power bank where you
can plug in a cable to charge your
iphone and your iphone will reverse
wireless charge the power bank but
apple's plan for the ipad pro is even
better because according to mark german
you're going to be able to recharge your
iphone your earpods and even your future
apple watch by using this new reverse
wireless charging feature on the back of
the ipad pro and if you're wondering how
that's gonna work the only answer is mac
save charging by using the mac safe puck
which mark german has already mentioned
so that you can use your ipad in the
upright position potentially with the
magic keyboard while also recharging
your devices magnetically using mac safe
at the same time and that actually makes
a lot of sense because both the airpods
3 and the airpods pro have recently been
updated with max safe charging support
which works great and i even made a
recent video discussing how apple could
easily build maxsafe into the next gen
magic keyboard as well so we can pass
through charge with multiple stacks of
coils so definitely watch that video but
with all that said if you think a full
glass back on an ipad pro is a little
insane because it's much more
susceptible to drops and cracks well you
are right because it has been reported
that apple hit a major roadblock and
plans to redesign the ipad pro and
according to 925 mac this glass back
ipad pro redesign may have been scrapped
because apple was concerned that the
ipad would become too fragile due to all
of the glass so unfortunately it looks
like the upcoming 2022 ipad pro is most
likely not gonna come with that full
glass back redesign but wait the story
doesn't end there because apple might
have an even better trick up their
sleeve according to 95 max sources apple
has actually been developing ipad pro
prototypes with large apple logos that
are made out of glass instead of metal
and if you think that's crazy 925 mac
pointed out that apple increased the
size of the apple logos on the new
macbook pros almost like they knew that
they were thinking of doing the same
thing for the ipad pro as well but
getting back to the potential glass
apple logo design this actually makes a
lot of sense because the glass would
allow wireless charging power to be
distributed through it and then as for
the max safe magnets the aluminum back
wouldn't matter at all because the ipad
pro already uses a ton of magnets for
connecting to the magic keyboard and
then of course the major benefit is that
the rest of the back will remain being
built out of metal so it's gonna be much
more durable and then getting into more
of the details they confirmed that one
of the prototypes featured magsafe
support which makes total sense but this
time with stronger magnets than you get
with the iphone to prevent accidental
damage so stronger magnets make a lot of
sense since you don't want your air pods
or even your iphone falling off of the
back of the ipad pro while charging and
then going even further they mentioned
that the magsafe charger will support
faster wireless charging speeds compared
to the 15 watts you get with the iphone
and this makes a lot of sense because
the ipad pro's battery is much larger
and takes more time to charge so apple
will either have an updated max safe
charger with faster charging just for
the ipad pro or they're just gonna up
the wattage because it handles heat much
better than the smaller iphones which
get pretty hot while back safe charging
and now with all that said everything
finally makes sense for apple to do this
especially since they've already
increased the size of the apple logo on
the new macbook pros so i ended up
deciding to actually grab a mac safe
puck charger and put it up against the
new macbook pro apple logo to see if
it's actually big enough to support
wireless charging if it was glass or if
apple is going to have to make it even
larger so what i ended up doing was i
found a tear down of the magsafe charger
online to see how big the actual
charging coils are compared to the puck
itself and then i grabbed a piece of
paper and drew a circle just to get a
rough idea of the size required to
support max safe charging and as you can
see on this macbook pro the coils on the
inside are just a bit larger than the
apple logo itself so apple would have to
make it even bigger on the new ipad pros
to make max a function through the glass
without any issues so finally i worked
with renders by shailesh to create some
new renders of what the new updated
design would look like with the larger
apple logo made out of glass and in my
opinion this looks absolutely fantastic
and it doesn't seem like the logo is way
too big at all the apple logo on the
current 12.9 inch ipad pro is laughably
small like it looks way too small right
now on that huge ipad pro chassis so it
makes sense for apple to increase the
logo size even if they weren't planning
on adding max safe support and if you're
wondering why the apple logo is placed
horizontally on my custom ipad pro
renders that's because the reliable
leaker dylan dkt claimed that the future
ipad pros will feature a horizontally
placed apple logo on the back because
they're planning on making landscape
mode the default for ipad pro usage and
then going back to my renders i also had
one more detail that you may have missed
the smart connector that we currently
have on the ipad pro is now gone on my
new renders of the 2022 ipad pro and the
reason i did that is because i fully
believe that the new ipad pro is going
to be able to power the magic keyboard
case using reverse wireless charging
through the mac safe connector so there
won't be any physical connectors at all
and if you think i'm totally crazy for
believing that i recently found some
ipad pro patents claiming that a new
future magic keyboard will come with two
sets of max safe charging coils
one set will be used for pass-through
charging the ipad pro and the second set
will be used to reverse wireless charge
accessories like an iphone air pods or
future apple watch and now on top of all
of that 9.5 mac did give us some extra
details like for example apple is
planning on increasing the battery size
on the new ipad pro to help offset the
loss and battery power when using the
magic keyboard especially since it's
going to be powered wirelessly in my
opinion so if you take all those rumors
and add them up together the whole idea
of going with the glass apple logo
actually makes the most sense because
from the outside you won't really notice
that it supports max life wireless
charging until you place the puck on
there or any of your other mac save
devices and you're not gonna risk any
damage from having a full glass back and
in terms of when we should expect this
new ipad pro i fully believe that it's
going to be coming this fall just based
on the one and a half year update cycle
that apple usually has for their ipad
pro especially since we're not expecting
the m2 chip to come out until the second
half of this year so with all that said
if you think the larger glass apple logo
is a good idea then go ahead and click
the circle about to subscribe for more
videos like this one and definitely
check out that video on those ipad pro
patents right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]